-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, this is big.
Today, President Biden
gave U.S. intelligence agencies
90 days to find out exactly
how COVID started.
Yep. Biden was like, "If you can
find a fiancé in 90 days,
you can find the truth
about COVID."
[ Laughter ]
"I believe that."
It's worth a shot. I mean,
if we've learned anything
from Marvel movies,
everyone loves
a good origin story, you know?
[ Laughter ]
And I'm excited,
'cause they've already cast
Timothée Chalamet
to play young COVID.
[ Laughter ]
So that's gonna be cool.
Yep, Biden wants
the COVID origin story now.
Then, in 10 years, he wants
a COVID reunion on HBO Max.
[ Laughter ]
I'm pretty sure this will end
with us tracing COVID
back to the same lab
that came up with the McRib.
[ Laughter ]
I love this.
It's in the shape of a rib,
isn't it?
-Ribbish.
-Ribbish, right?
Like, bone-in?
-Eh, no.
It looks like a bone-in rib.
-Like, it looks like the thing
that flipped over
Fred Flintstone's car.
-Exactly.
That big, like a bronto-rib.
-I love it.
Here's some more big news.
Last night, it came out that a
grand jury is hearing evidence
against former President Trump
and could indict him.
-Ooh.
-Yep.
Trump knew he was in trouble
when he called his lawyer
and the FBI
answered Rudy's phone.
[ Laughter ]
"You're being recorded."
We know a trial is close
when the courtroom sketch artist
goes to Michael's and says,
"Give me all the orange crayons
you have."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"It's going down.
It's going down."
[ Applause ]
Of course,
Trump responded to the news
in his official statement.
He said,
"It's a total witch hunt."
Then he added,
"I'm completely innocent."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, he said,
"Now if you'll excuse me,
I have to catch a flight
to Mexico."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
He's innocent.
Some news from the U.K.
Apparently, at the start
of the pandemic, British
Prime Minister Boris Johnson
wanted to be injected with COVID
on live TV
so people could see there's
nothing to be scared of.
[ Laughter ]
Once again, no good idea
has ever started with,
"I'm gonna inject myself."
[ Laughter ]
Boris was like,
"In hindsight, it was stupid."
[ Laughter ]
And then opened a Starbucks
bathroom door with his mouth.
"Aaaah!"
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
as we head into summer,
I read that there's already
a big shortage of fireworks.
-Ooh.
-That's not good,
'cause the only thing worse
than mixing booze and fireworks
is mixing booze
and bootleg fireworks.
That's what I say.
[ Laughter ]
"I don't know
what the heck it does.
Just light it."
[ Laughter ]
"Don't go near it!"
"All right.
One selfie -- that's it.
Then don't touch it!
Oh, look,
the dog's playing with it.
Oh, that's fun."
[ Laughter ]
"All right.
Take it out of his mouth."
Some guys are gonna be like,
"Well, I guess we could just
deep-fry a turkey
and hope for the worst."
[ Laughter ]
Listen to this.
In Virginia, a man created
a COVID-safe way
for people to --
I love inventions.
-Yeah.
-I love inventions.
-You do.
-They're my favorite.
I really do.
So, this man in Virginia
created a COVID-safe way
for people to blow out
birthday candles
by inventing a device
that's called the Blowzee.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's a good idea,
but I'm not sure I want the word
Blowzee showing up
on my credit-card statement.
[ Laughter ]
And get this -- I read that over
$1 million worth of cocaine
tied to life jackets
washed up on a beach in England.
Police got to work on the case
while the SyFy Channel
got to work on "Cocaine Shark."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'd watch --
I'd watch "Cocaine Shark."
-Yeah.
-Finally, new research estimates
that the oldest maximum age
humans can live is 150 years.
Right now, there's a
149-year-old who's like,
"I thought I'd have more time."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Guys, a lot of people
are talking about
President Biden's $1.7 trillion
infrastructure plan.
This, by the way,
is my new voice.
-You like it?
I like the black shirt,
the black tie,
and the smokey voice.
-It's almost like
a new character.
-Yeah.
-It's a whole new me.
-Chip.
-Chip?
[ Laughter ]
No, no, no.
I think his name is, like, Jack.
-Jack or Jake.
-Jack Fallon.
Jake Fallon?
Is this a Jake Fallon or Jack?
-Jake.
-I think it's Jake.
-Jake?
-Jake.
-Ya-ksh!
[ Laughter ]
-Jake!
-After every joke...
-Wa-ksh!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-I don't know
if it's a bluesy thing.
It's more like
techno streets of Tokyo.
-Right.
Like you're going --
You're futuristic.
-Yeah. It's raining out.
-Right, like "Blade Runner."
-It's raining out.
There's a bunch of neon.
-Right.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
"Come on! I've got
to get you out of here!"
♪♪
-Jake Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sorry.
I lost my voice the other night,
so now --
'Cause I was singing with --
When you have a sing-along with
Dave Grohl, that's what happens.
-What a better way
to lose your voice.
-It's the best way
Anyways --
-I was yelling at my kids,
and I lost my voice.
That's not fun.
"Get out of here!
Get off my lawn!"
-That's not a charming story.
[ Laughter ]
-They weren't my kids.
They were somebody else's kids.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And you call them your kids.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, the neighborhood kids.
You know.